some of the steps Joaquin Phoenix took
to become Gotham's Clown Prince of Crime
seem pretty risky which is par for the
course when you're an actor of his
caliber but what exactly did Phoenix do
to prepare for such a disturbing role
here's how the celebrated performer
transformed himself into the Joker
Joaquin Phoenix says he didn't study any
previous film incarnations of the Joker
in preparation and that may be
technically true but there's one silent
film he did study that's essentially a
joker origin story at the 2019 Venice
Film Festival joker director Todd
Phillips said one of the movies he and
Phoenix found particularly important for
Joker prep was the 1928 silent film the
man who laughs based on the Victor Hugo
novel of the same name the film is about
a man who has been disfigured with a
permanent smile since birth and becomes
a sideshow attraction the man who laughs
is often cited as the inspiration for
the Joker who premiered in 1940's Batman
number one DC comic book writer Grant
Morrison in fact called the Joker a
direct lift from the man who laughs in
his 2011 book super gods he goes so far
to say it's a wonder how Joker's
creators got away with copying the film
so in a sense even though the Joker's of
Heath Ledger or Jack Nicholson weren't
considered in the creation of Arthur
Fleck you could argue Phillips and
Phoenix studied every Joker by skipping
them all and going straight to the
source Phillips has been clear he
doesn't want anyone to go into Joker
thinking they're going to be seeing an
adaptation of a particular comic or that
they should expect much inspiration from
the comics at all but there's at least
one way Arthur flex character mirrors
the Joker of the comics perhaps more
closely than any of the film adaptations
we've seen so far the Joker is almost
always depicted as being very skinny in
the comics sometimes impossibly so
according to Phoenix the first thing he
did to prepare for Joker was to lose
weight which had a welcome side effect
he said at the Venice Film Festival the
first thing for us was the weight loss I
think that's really what I started with
as it turns out that then affects your
psychology you start to go mad when you
lose that amount of weight in that
amount of
while the man who laughs came out in
1928 other films influencing Joker came
from a very different era
specifically the 70s and early 80s that
probably isn't a surprise as soon as the
first Joker trailer was released fans
and critics saw the similarities to
specific 70s films particularly those
directed by acclaimed director Martin
Scorsese who was originally attached as
an executive producer for Joker but had
to bow out due to conflicting
commitments Phillips named 1976's taxi
driver and 1982's King of Comedy as some
of his chief inspirations for Joker both
of which star Robert De Niro King of
Comedy like Joker follows a failed and
mentally ill stand-up comic played by De
Niro in funhouse mirror style De Niro
pops up in Joker as an established
talk-show host
facing a mentally ill comedian of his
own for other inspirations Phillips also
mentioned 1973's Serpico in 1975 s One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest the
highlight in the career of one of the
most memorable movie Jokers Jack
Nicholson films weren't the only media
Joaquin Phoenix studied to become the
Joker at the Venice Film Festival he
mentioned reading a book that broke down
the personality types of political
assassins we don't know exactly which
books he read because he didn't offer
specifics though one likely candidate
might be James W Clarke's 1990 book on
being mad or merely angry which among
other things looks at John Hinckley's
1981 assassination attempt on President
Ronald Reagan regardless of exactly what
Phoenix read the subject is telling in
terms of the departure from previous
incarnations of the Joker while the
Joker of the comics and other films
would likely have a few qualms about
killing politicians it's not his primary
focus it also speaks to just how
strongly the film's Phillips mentioned
will influence Joker political
assassination is very much on Travis
bickel's mind in 1976 his taxi driver
and the early 80s setting of Joker
places it right around the time
Hinckley's own mental illness drove him
to try to assassinate President Reagan
in Venice Phoenix talked about how
writing a journal for Arthur Fleck
helped him to begin to form the
character he told reporters that Todd
Phillips sent him a blank notebook to
act as flex journal and joke diaries
saying that was really helpful because I
had been there for a couple of weeks and
wasn't sure how I was going to start I
didn't know what to write so I asked
Philips for some suggestions and after a
few days I ignored his suggestions and
suddenly it was coming out it became a
really important part of the discovery
of the character we may have already
gotten a glimpse at Phoenix's journal or
perhaps just a version inspired by it in
the first Joker trailer Phoenix says one
of the things that makes his take on the
Joker feel so fresh has to do with his
approach to the character as a persona
that already exists within Arthur Fleck
just fighting to emerge the actor said
one of the earliest things he tackled
was the mad man's infamous laugh
according to Phoenix it wasn't easy to
nail down he told the press in Venice
before I even read the script Todd came
over and talked me through what he
wanted out of this character and this
movie and he described the laughter as
something that was almost painful
honestly I didn't think that I could do
it I would practice alone and then ask
Todd to come over to audition my laugh
because I felt like I had to do it on
the spot and in front of somebody else
it took me a long time reviewing the
final trailer with Phoenix's words in
mind is interesting during his
confrontation with Thomas Wayne you can
hear what Phoenix is talking about as
far as the laughter being almost painful
earlier when he laughs loudly and then
abruptly stops it sure sounds like a
moment of the Joker trying to emerge
see the fruit of Phoenix's twisted labor
when Joker hits theaters October 4th
2019 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite comic book movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]